we have to support the Palestinians and
what they need and we have to confer
with the qataris this is Democrat former
Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi back
in
2014 saying that Hamas is a humanitarian
organization war is a is is a deadly
thing and I have many Palestinians who
live in my district and I'm hearing from
them regularly about how their families
are affected who live in the region it's
a terrible thing but let me just say
that any missile that comes from
someplace has a return address and if
Israel is responding to that address uh
uh
then such a shame that the Palestinians
are using uh aruma to be using children
and families as shields for their for
their missiles uh should we all try to
you first of all avoid conflict the
Hamas initiated this so again this this
has to be something where we try to have
the two-state solution that we have to
support we have to support abas and his
role as leader there we have to support
IR doome to protect the Israelis from
the missiles we have to support the
Palestinians and what they need and we
have to confer with the qataris who have
told me over and over again that Hamas
is a humanitarian organization maybe
they could use their influence uh to um
uh to US thinks they're a terrorist
organization though correct to you yeah
um we've had that discussion
guys I thought this was the perfect clip
to start with because we're seeing so
many people usually Democrats and
mainstream media New York Times CNN Etc
definitely MSNBC just repeat talking
points that line there at the end well
she talked to the qaris and the Qatari
said that Hamas was a humanitarian
organization now remember this is this
is nine years ago I want to reference
one other thing before you guys jump in
she also mentions abas now she's talking
about Palestinian Authority president
mmud abas who has not had elections in
about 20 years or so so uh and she's
saying we have to help him well just
this morning just literally just this
morning uh the Palestinian Authority
released an official document that
they're sending to all the mosques in
the West Bank uh and it calls actually
for the direct incitement to murder of
Jews not just those pesky settlers or
Israelis and they quote the Quran in it
we're showing the image right now right
so I can't read all the Arabic I'm a
little behind on my Arabic studies but
uh you're going to have to take my word
for it or you can check on Twitter for a
full translation of the whole thing uh
James let me start with you on this um
this this sort of collapse that we've
seen of the Democrat Party the the
abandonment of liberalism and the
running of cover for a lot of the bad
guys I take it you're not very surprised
by any of it I am completely not
surprised completely not surprised I
mean if anybody's been actually paying
attention to the rhetoric not just from
now I have to confess like you don't
speak Arabic I don't speak drunk very
well anymore I left college so she was
pretty
yeah back in the day though she was way
more cogent yeah so um as it turns out
anybody who's been paying attention to
what they've been saying what they've
been writing could have seen the writing
on the wall for example a lot of people
realize that the Democrats and the left
in general have been kind of been thrall
to this character named Angela Davis who
is kind of a domestic terrorist here in
the US openly communist this kind of
stuff and she said that she was
radicalized first when she was at UCLA
underneath or UCSD one or the other
underneath Herbert Marcus the most
famous of the
neo-marxists uh and then she said she
was radicalized the second time when
when she went to Palestine and so
there's been this palestin she's written
books about this there's been this
Palestinian uh kind of leftist Alliance
running for a very very long time it's
been an undercurrent in the left for
this entire time I was just in George
Floyd Square about a week ago and guess
what there's a mural of Angela Davis
what a big surprise this is the current
of the left and so if if you studied ma
as I've unfortunately had the
the displeasure of doing um ma said that
what he did in the 1940s was he used his
formula his famous formula of unity
criticism Unity to first concentrate
power in the Communist party and then
use that concentrated power to overthrow
China in 1949 and this is exactly what I
think we've seen progress over the past
maybe 15
years